I got the latest news on the coronavirus  yeah you should all right yeah no yeah  and you and you thought this was a  comedy show yeah no yeah this is the  latest vice president Mike Pence has  been put in charge of stopping the  spread of the corona virus in the United  States yes yes yes in other words it's  been nice knowing you  we're done for all of us are done for I  love people clapping along with that we  have ours ladies and gentlemen ours now  it's true president Trump has put Mike  Pence in charge of combating the corona  virus that is the big story which is why  today pence announced the corona virus  can be cured by heterosexual marriage so  [Laughter]  just keep joylessly procreating in Los  Angeles true story a man was caught  stealing a hearse with a dead body  inside yes now sometimes the urge to  drive in the carpool lane is  you